thank you
[Applause]
good morning Mr President good morning
Madam Ambassador who was with us this
morning Madam ambassador
Ambassador Makarova
Mr President it is my honor to present
to you the Congress of the United States
which has great respect and admiration
and appreciation for your courageous
leadership members of Congress I have
the high privilege and distinct honor of
presenting to you the president of
Ukraine Vladimir zielinski Flava ukrana
[Applause]
thank you
great to hear us
my colleagues Slava ukrana
[Applause]
glory to Heroes
thank you very much
Madam speaker members of the Congress
ladies and gentlemen
Americans friends
I'm proud to greet you from Ukraine from
our capital city of cave a city that is
under missile and airstrikes from
Russian troops every day but it doesn't
give up
and we have not even thought about it
for a second just like many other cities
and communities in our beautiful country
which found themselves in the worst war
since World War II
I have the honor to greet you on behalf
of the Ukrainian people Brave and
freedom loving people who for eight
years have been resisting the Russian
aggression
those who give their best
Sons and Daughters to stop this
full-scale Russian invasion
right now the destiny of our country
is being decided
the destiny of our people whether
ukrainians will be free whether they
will be able to preserve their democracy
Russia has attacked not just us not just
our land not just our cities it went on
a brutal offensive against our values
basic human values it through tanks and
planes against our freedom against our
right to live freely in our own country
choosing our own future
against our desire for happiness against
our national dreams just like the same
dreams you have you Americans
just
like anyone else in the United States I
remember your National Memorial in
Rushmore
the faces of your prominent presidents
those who laid the foundation of the
United States of America as it is today
democracy Independence freedom and care
for everyone for every person for
everyone who works diligently who lives
honestly who respects the law we in
Ukraine won the same for our people
all that is normal part of your own life
ladies and gentlemen
friends Americans in your great history
you have pages that would allow you to
understand ukrainians understand us now
when you need it right now when we need
you right now remember Pearl Harbor
terrible morning of December 7 1941 when
your sky was black from the planes
attacking you just remember it remember
September the 11th a terrible day in 20
2001 when evil tried to turn your cities
independent territories
in battlefields when innocent people
were attacked
attacked from Air yes
just like nobody else expected it you
could not stop it our country
experienced the same every day right now
at this moment every night for three
weeks now various Ukrainian cities
Odessa and Carthage
Russia has turned the Ukrainian Sky into
a source of death for thousands of
people
Russian troops have already fired nearly
1 000 missiles at Ukraine countless
bombs they use drones to kill us with
Precision this is a terror that Europe
has not seen has not seen for 80 years
and we are asking for a reply for an
answer to this Terror from the whole
world is this a lot to ask for to create
a no-fly zone Zone over Ukraine to save
people is this too much to ask
humanitarian no-fly zone
something that Ukraine that Russia would
not be able to terrorize our free cities
if this is too much to ask we offer an
alternative you know what kind of
Defense systems we need as 300 and other
similar systems you know how much
depends on the battlefield on the
ability to use aircraft powerful strong
Air Aviation to protect our people our
freedom our land aircraft that can help
Ukraine
help Europe
and you know that they exist and you
have them but they are on Earth not in
Ukraine in the Ukrainian Sky they do not
defend our people I have a dream these
words are known to each of you today I
can say I have a need
I need to protect our Sky I need your
decision your health which means exactly
the same the same you feel when you hear
the words I have a dream
ladies and gentlemen friends
Ukraine is grateful to the United States
for its overwhelming support for
everything that U.S government and your
people have done for us for weapons and
ammunition for training for finances for
leadership in the Free World which helps
us to pressure the aggressor
economically I am grateful to President
Biden for his personal involvement for
his sincere commitment to the defense of
Ukraine and democracy all over the world
I am grateful to you for the resolution
which recognizes All Those who commit
crimes against Ukraine against the
Ukrainian people as war criminals
however now it is true in the darkest
time for our country for the whole
Europe I call on you to do more new
packages of sanctions are needed
constantly every week until the Russian
military machine stops
restrictions are needed for everyone on
whom there's unjust regime is based we
propose that the United States sanctions
all politicians in the Russian
Federation who remain in their offices
and do not
cut ties with those who are responsible
for the aggression against Ukraine from
State Dumas members to the last official
who has lack of morale to break the
state Terror all Americans company must
leave Russia from their Market leave
their Market
immediately because it is flooded with
our blood ladies and gentlemen members
of Congress please take the lead if you
have companies in your districts who
finance the Russian military machine
leaving business in Russia you should
put pressure I'm asking to make sure
that the Russians do not receive a
single penny that they use to destroy
people in Ukraine
the destruction of our country the
destruction of Europe All American ports
should be closed for uh Russian Goods we
um Peace is more important than income
and we have to defend this principle in
the whole world we already became part
of the anti-work Coalition a big
anti-war Coalition that unites many
countries dozens of countries those who
reacted to in principle to President
Putin's decision to invade our country
but we need to move on and do more we
need to create new tools to respond
quickly and stop the war the full-scale
Russian invasion of Ukraine which began
on February 24th and it would be fair if
it ended in a day in 24 hours that evil
would be punished immediately
today the world does not have such tools
the war of the past have prompted our
predecessors to create institutions
that should protect us from war but they
unfortunately don't work we see it you
see it so we need new ones new
institutions new alliances and we offer
them we propose to create an association
U24 United for peace a union of
responsible countries that have the
strengths and Consciousness to stop
conflicts immediately provide all the
necessary assistance in 24 hours if
necessary even weapons if necessary
sanctions humanitarian support political
support finances everything you need to
keep the peace and quickly
save the world to save lives in addition
such associations such unions could
provide assistance to those who are
experienced natural disasters man-made
disasters who felt victims to
humanitarian crisis or epidemics
remember how difficult it was for the
world to do the simplest thing just to
give vaccines vaccines against covet to
save lives to prevent new strains the
world spent months years doing things
like that much faster to make sure there
are no human losses no victims ladies
and gentlemen Americans if such Alliance
would exist today that is U24 we would
be able to save thousands of lives in
our country
in many countries of the world those who
need peace
those who suffer inhumane destruction I
ask you to watch one video video of what
the Russian troops did in our country in
our land we have to stop it we must
prevent it preventively destroy every
single aggressor who seeks to subjugate
other nations please watch the video
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
in the end to sum it up
today
today it's not enough to be the leader
of the niche
today it takes to be the leader of the
world being the leader of the world
means to be the leader of peace
peace in your country doesn't depend
anymore only on you and your people
it depends on those next to you
and those who are strong
strong doesn't mean big
strong is brave and ready to fight for
the life of his citizens and citizens of
the world
of human rights for freedom for the
right to live instantly and to die when
your time comes
and not when it's wanted by someone else
by your neighbor
today the Ukrainian people are defending
not only Ukraine we are fighting for the
values of Europe and the world
sacrificing our lives in the name of the
future
that's why today the American people are
helping not just Ukraine
but Europe and the world to keep the
planet alive
to keep Justice in history
now I am almost 45 years old today my
age stopped when the heart of more than
100 children
of beating I see no sense in life
if it cannot stop the deaths
and this is my main mission at the
leader of my people great ukrainians
and at the leader of my Niche I am
addressing the President Biden
you are the leader
of the niche
of your relationship
I wish you to be the leader of the world
being the leader of the world means to
be the leader of peace
thank you slave
glory to Ukraine
good for your support
foreign